um how you doing how you doing um
i'm a big supporter of the daily wire
thank you like ben shapiro
regardless what people think of him i'm
a little like
lukewarm on him but that's okay i see
how he thinks about you
um what i don't understand is um why a
lot of my own people don't see that
the democratic party is politicizing us
and using us to
pass laws that aren't gonna actually
benefit us
i i feel like they're like a lot of us
are blind
you know with as far as speaking english
or spanish
i couldn't imagine going to china and
not learning the language how would i
go find where the bathroom is or any
other country
and but yet but i don't think people
should not speak the language they could
speak it in their house but how would
they communicate with their neighbors
you know i i i'm wondering when i'm
being proud to be an american
became racist when america doesn't have
a race
you know i'm wondering exactly the same
thing
i'm wondering exactly the same thing
i think part of that is because you have
people we've now heard from two
faculty members at this university who
have said that if you hold the opinions
that you and i hold
that we are fascist we are racist and we
are committing
violence against latinos apparently
you're committing violence against
latinos i didn't know this
you're apparently self-flagellating or
something like that this
this is an opinion held by two white
liberal people
who are teaching at this university and
i point them out
because it creates a culture that
stifles free speech
it is no accident that the vast majority
of virtually every voting demographic in
this country
including hispanics including democrats
opposes
illegal immigration and yet in the
popular culture if you were to say that
you would be baselessly smeared as some
sort of bigot
or some sort of fascist or some sort
whatever stupid slur
you want to throw in the only thing that
we can possibly do is speak up and look
them in the eye and convince our
neighbors
and not allow them to bully us and shut
us up but it looks like nobody's going
to bully and shut you up so
that's a very good thing i i find it
funny that these
two non-mexican professors are trying to
speak for me i don't need
anybody to defend my race for me i
wonder how many
uh mexicans that they help on a daily
basis if they're buying flowers off of
people
on the side of the freeways or if
they're judging people like me
you know when we walk by them you know i
i get judged on my race a lot by these
people but yet in these kind of
forums they pretend they pretend to
defend us and it's very hypocritical
like i'm standing in the back while
you're trying to answer questions and
they're screaming
uh don't interrupt her as they're
interrupting you
and and the hip the hypocrisy is real
and i just want to say that
not everybody of my race thinks like
they do
you know there's there's a bunch of us
who are waking up and uh
i just want to let people know that you
know we're not all a monolith
you know of course everything you've
said is absolutely right
i wish i think unfortunately those
professors left
so those professors didn't show you the
courtesy that you showed to them you
listened to their question in the answer
they didn't show you that same courtesy
i'm not surprised at all
generally speaking white liberals are
very good at being offended
on behalf of other people they never ask
the other people's opinions
they ever ask what they feel about it
they're just very good
at unfortunately exploiting racial
and sexual and identity politics to push
their own agendas regardless
of the consequences of those policies on
the people that they're pretending to
help and in the case of
illegal immigration this leads to
widespread violence sexual violence
and violence for 70 of people who cross
that border illegally it's
it's disgraceful and it's their it's the
way that they conduct politics
unfortunately